mythicquest is the greatest show in the
history of television
all the writers tons of the directors a
bunch of actors
roomfuls emmys seems like everybody's
got emmy except me
[Music]
we've been really fortunate to be able
to come back for a season two
and the entire team has just been
incredible we started shooting the
season and then got shut down because of
the pandemic
and coming back into production really
required a lot of patience a lot of
hey snoop doggy dog what's poppin bert
it's brad but that's fine first show
even though this is a games company i
think what's really cool about it is
that it's much more universal
you're working in an office with other
people so they're the same sorts of
problems
people navigating work life navigating
love life navigating life in general
i'm a great boss tell him dana no sister
girl done flipped the script
david david david i'm sorry i think that
it's hot it is about a found family
it's fun to watch because it's really
easy to relate to that
what is that what's happening i can fix
it i i just need to
oh no she just crashed all the servers
in season two we got more jokes very
groovy
we got badass women i think you're the
most talented programmer
of our generation we get to expose like
these deeper character traits within the
cast
what are you doing i'm hiding my office
until he leaves
is it yes it is joel there's bitterness
envy jealous rage you're a toilet
but we're family and we have a better
season because of it
it's this tremendous powerful cinematic
explosion
there's much to be discovered and i'm so
proud to be part of it
even though i was included as a zoom
head
how do i look actually well somebody
rolled his ass out of here
i feel so grateful to create something
authentic to people's experience
and i love coming to work for that very
reason it's just the people
you